is so continuing our discussion on
Marvel's first black superhero following
Adam Beshear stepping down from his role
as a blue marvel at the request of the
president rather than jumping back and
forth between the past and the current
events this section of the story instead
focuses largely on the present-day
picking up with Tony Stark Reed Richards
and Hank Pym Kevin Grebo uses the
Avengers battle against anti man to
present a sense of urgency and that to
them they have never faced a being of
such power before with the century
counted as the strongest of their ranks
but being dispatched readily and with
minimal effort the questions remain as
to who the anti man is how he gained his
power and how to stop him furthermore as
hey Pam mentions during the battle ante
man had referenced the blue marvel and
while Reed had picked up on this as well
his only knowledge of Adam was that he
had acted as a superhero at some point
during the 1960's now this is
particularly important and the reason
why is that is arguably the smartest
person in the world a title the flux
choice between himself and doom Reed has
access to some of the best technology
and a library of knowledge but despite
everything he knows the concept of the
blue Marvel is ambiguous here and not to
the best of Reed's knowledge the blue
Marvel had died during a battle but he
doesn't recall any of his exploits now
what this does is established just how
obscure the blue Marvel is as well as
the fact that he had left the superhero
scene long before the dawn of the
Fantastic Four
furthermore Reed also provides us with
some information on the power of an T
man and that according to his readings
the ante man had been getting weaker
towards the close of the fight and that
his dissipation was due to completely
running out of energy
furthermore Reed's analysis led him to
the conclusion that the anti man is
composed or powered by antimatter itself
while Tony Stark rejects this idea what
Kevin Grebo does is provide us with a
simplified version of the relationship
between normal matter and antimatter
according to read under normal
circumstances when antimatter and normal
matter combine the result is explosive
with both objects being completely
eliminated
however because anti man is powered by
antimatter as opposed to being made of
it antimatter works more like a battery
that powers the ante man who in turn
uses his connection to antimatter energy
to achieve his incredible strength
invulnerability and other powers and so
while reading him direct their efforts
to locating the source of antimatter
power Tony Stark spends his time focused
on trying to bridge the gap between the
time Blue Marble disappeared and the
current day at this point
Griffith Incans the plot of the story
and if I can be honest here for the rest
of the issue the events that transpire
will serve to demonstrate how good of a
writer grubo truly is with tony stark
standing as a director of shield he
currently has access to the database of
all intelligence organization around the
world however during a search of the
blue Marvel the only piece of
information he can locate comes through
a single KGB file which had previously
been accessed and held by the NSA
however when he tries to access the
information we learned that the file has
been sealed and secured by executive
order something that could only be done
by the President of the United States
with the revelation that this file
contains something referred to as a blue
Marvel protocols once dark muses to
himself as to what the protocols are he
finds himself granted access to the
information contained within from here
we jump to Tony Stark meeting with
dum-dum Dugan the side track for a
second Dugan was one of the original
Howling Commandos and served as Nick
Fury second-in-command during World War
two in addition to this when Nick Fury
was promoted to the position of
executive director of shield following
its creation during the early 1960s
Dugan had remained on board as one of
Fury's most trusted agents now the
conversation between the two tells us
that during the era of blue Marvel not
only which shield active but they were
well aware of who Adam Brashear was and
what he had done and his quest to
protect the earth and whilst our
questions Dugan regarding what he knows
about blue Marvel Duggan's initial
reaction is a tell stark to leave it
alone
now I'll start believes that Dugan was
part of the cover-up the discussion
between the two is based on information
that we haven't received yet but putting
two and two together the situation seems
to have been the following blue Marvel
stepping down at the President's request
shield had been tasked with monitoring
Brashear for reasons unknown however
because shield existed outside the
authority of any existing government
during that time fury turned down the
request of the President to monitor
Brashear due to the fact that neither
Fury nor any of his group agreed with
the fact that Brashear had been
blackballed now when the question is
asked by stark as to why blue Marvel was
asked to step down in the first place
Dugan reiterates the same concerns
expressed by President Kennedy and that
because the United States was in the
midst of social turmoil regarding race
relations the United States government
did not want to be stuck behind the
eight-ball with an extremely powerful
being working
against them and with no recourse of
their own furthermore as a conversation
between the two begins to wrap up the
question is asked that with all the
power that shield had including the
power to overrule any government in the
world why didn't they use that power to
back blue marvel rather than letting the
president send him off now where Dubin
refuses to answer the question due to
the fact that he fears his words will be
twisted and he'll appear to be a racist
the answer to this question is that the
purpose of shield is to monitor threats
to the planet earth not to involve
itself in the political entanglements of
individual countries and so because Tony
Stark is so persistent about discovering
what happened to blue Marvel and whether
or not he's still alive Dugan defers him
to a man named Kreutz the same general
that referred to blue Marvel as a porch
monkey in our first video and while
stark prepares to leave Dugan warns him
that traveling down this path may lead
stark to learning about things that he
won't like now transitioning to a place
called Church Falls Virginia a small
community just outside of Arlington we
learned that after the battle between
the Avengers and the anti man was
broadcast on television Kreutz had come
to the conclusion that at some point
stark would come looking for him in
search of blue Marvel now the
conversation that takes place between
the two is very important for a couple
of reasons the first is because Kreutz
will remove some of the mystery
surrounding blue Marvel and what it was
it happened to him but also because
Grebo is going to use this exchange to
highlight how the world has changed and
the difference between how a majority of
society used to think regarding African
Americans and how they think now from
the perspective of Cruz the issue of
Adam Bashir was as much national as it
was global when world war ii had ended
in europe was being carved up by both
the United States and the Soviet Union
the Cold War came into fruition as the
two nations attempted to expand their
spheres of influence regarding
capitalism and communism as a result
while the second Red Scare only lasted
between 1947 and 1957 the concern of
communist ideology spreading to the
United States was still very real this
combined with the belief that Adam
Brashear could have been another
extremist like Malcolm X or an
insurrectionist like Gabriel Prosser a
man who led a slave rebellion in the
summer of 1871 to a corner believing
that brashears actions could have
brought ruin to the entire country had
he turned against the United States
this sentiment was compounded on by men
like ball of our Trask who used the
efforts of blue Marvel to further their
own anti-mutant agenda by arguing that
even if rich Shearer was not a mutant
while he existed prior to the formation
of the x-men he was an indication that
super-powered people were emerging
because a government would be unable to
control them if super-powered people
were to band together they could top of
the world's governments and if they
descend into civil war they could
destabilize the world's socio-economic
environment as a result in addition to
blue Marvel being asked to step down by
Kennedy his actions led to the federal
government launching project wide-awake
a joint effort by the Defense Department
the CIA the National Security Council
all headed by Henry Peter Garrick which
would go on to see the creation and
implementation of sentinels and so in
order to in the legacy of blue Marvel
before being asked to step down by
President Kennedy he had called blue
Marvel n for final mission which had
been classified above top-secret at some
point the US government's early warning
system had detected an alien presence
heading toward the planet earth calling
bashira in to deal with the alien the
primary goal was to assess and
neutralize the threat but the secondary
goal was to put bushier in a situation
where he may have been killed in action
with Russia R and the alien engaging in
battle we learned that from the
information gathered by shield
intelligence the alien was a scout for
an invading Armada looking to either
conquer or destroy the earth while the
situation seemed evenly matched with
bashir on the ropes and possibly being
killed by the alien during the battle he
was able to muster his power together
and in turn destroy the alien and so his
crew concludes his story by telling
stark that this was the last time he had
ever seen Brashear Starks response is
that Brashear was the only person who
had knowledge on who an T man was and
how to defeat him but rather than being
able to speak with Bashir and learn what
he knew about an t man the government
sent him on a suicide mission in an
effort to maintain control of the United
States however what curve O does here is
drop a massive bomb I having Kreutz
informed stark that blue marvel's death
was a ruse in order to ensure that he
wouldn't become a martyr by those who
look to capitalize on his legacy for
their own ends the meeting between
President Kennedy and blue Marvel was
organized in secret with all other
branches of the intelligence agencies
being led to believe that blue Marvel
had died fighting the alien and
protecting the earth as well as
providing a set of blue Marvel protocols
that were incomplete handing Tony Stark
a complete set of protocols
contains all information on Adam
Brashear we pick up in Maryland with a
woman named Candace Brashear revealing
that Adam is still alive Tony Stark
asked Candace if her husband is
available but because it's Thursday
Candace inform stark that her husband is
a teacher and has a late class becoming
frustrated over the fact that stark is
being ambiguous as to why they're
pursuing Adam Tony calls Candace by
another name miss Frazier while we're
not initially told what the significance
of this is the reaction of Candace
indicates that her current identity is a
false one something that's confirmed
when stark reveals that Candace's real
name is Marlene Frazier and establishes
that she's an agent of the federal
government informing her that he's read
the complete blue Marvel protocols and
is aware that Adam Brashear is alive but
does not know where he's located as a
story comes to a close the events
transition to the physics department of
the University of Maryland as Adam
concludes his class assigning a chapter
on the Heisenberg uncertainty principle
a concept of quantum mechanics that
deals with the contradiction of
trajectory of matter and observation
Adam receives a call from his wife
Candace advising him that shield is
looking for him with that being said
we're gonna bring this video to an end I
don't know about you guys but I love
this story so far
and I will catch you guys later peace